bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler d'un des phénomènes les plus
intrigants de la mécanique quantique ce
qu'on appelle l'intrication alors
j'avais déjà fait une vidéo
d'introduction à la mécanique quantique
et pour ceux qui ne se souviendrait pu
très bien ce qu'il y avait dedans
assurez-vous je faire des rappels
mais bon pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
connaîtraient vraiment rien à la
mécanique quantique
je vous conseille quand même d'aller y
faire un petit tour d'abord non à la
dernière chance
je voulais dit on va commencer par un
petit rappel sur la manière dont
fonctionne la mécanique quantique
l'idée centrale c'est qu'en mécanique
quantique les objets comme les
particules elle non plus des propriétés
bien définis par exemple elles ont pu
forcément une position où une vitesse
bien déterminée mais elles peuvent être
dans une superposition de plusieurs
états un électron par exemple bon bah il
peut être dans un état où sa vitesse et
mille kilomètres par seconde dans un
état où sa vitesse et deux mille
kilomètres par seconde donc ça c'est
normal mais il peut aussi être dans une
superposition de ces deux états et on
note ça comme ça en additionnant les
états entre décrocher cette idée que les
propriétés des objets ne soient plus
définie elle est déjà perturbante en soi
mais là où la mécanique quantique
devient vraiment bizarre c'est quand on
commence à vouloir mesurer quand même
ses propriétés si on considère un
électron qui est dans la superposition
de ces deux états et qu'on essaye de
mesurer sa vitesse
qu'est ce qu'on va trouver comme
résultat eh ben on a 50 % de chances de
trouver mille kilomètres par seconde et
50% de chances de mesurer deux mille
kilomètres par seconde
et si on mesure un grand nombre
d'électrons qui sont tous au départ dans
le même état on aura à peu près 50 50 de
chaque résultat mais si vous isolez un
électron en particulier vous n'avez
aucun moyen de savoir à l'avancé quels
résultats vous allez obtenir ça ne se
décide qu au moment de la mesure et
c'est le fruit du hasard en mécanique
quantique le hasard intervient dans les
mesurer à ce qu'on appelle un
déterminisme de la mesure alors quand on
regarde ça à première vue il ya quand
même de quoi être sceptique 1 on nous
dit que les particules sont dans des
états superposés premier truc bizarre et
on nous dit que quand on essaye de
mesurer les propriétés de ces objets qui
a une sorte de hasard cosmique qui
choisit le résultat deuxième truc
bizarre est-ce que c'est pas tout
simplement que dès le départ n'y a pas
du tout été à superposer il ya juste un
mélange de deux types d'électrons la
moitié des électrons qui vont déjà à
mille kilomètres par seconde et donc
quand on line buraud trouve mille
kilomètres par seconde
et puis l'autre moitié des électrons qui
vont déjà à deux mille kilomètres par
seconde et seront donc toujours mesuré à
deux mille kilomètres par seconde
et ben non la mécanique quantique
affirme que cette vision n'est pas
correct elle nous dit que on peut très
bien avoir au départ tout un tas
d'électrons qui sont tous exactement
dans le même état un état superposé et
que c'est la mesure qui va les forcer en
quelque sorte à choisir leur vitesse et
que le résultat de cette mesure
il est vraiment la conséquence d'un
hasard fondamental qu'on peut pas
prédire
vous y croyez vous non eh ben pour aller
dans votre sens sachez qu einstein qui
était quand même pas la moitié d'un
imbécile
ils y croyaient pas non plus einstein il
n'aimait pas du tout cette idée de
hasard fondamentale qui décideraient du
résultat des mesures sa situation et les
fameuses pour lui dieu ne joue pas aux
dés et notamment à la célèbre conférence
solveig 1927 on voit une photo ici il a
eu plein de débats avec le danois niels
bohr qui lui défend des l'idée d'un
hasard fondamental c'est une vision
qu'on appelle depuis l'interprétation de
copenhague mais d'un figurez-vous que
quelques années plus tard einstein a
enfin trouvé l'argument qui tue celui
qui allait clouer le bec de bord enfin
c'est ce qu'ils croyaient mais pour vous
expliquer tout ça il faut d'abord que je
vous parle du spin
le spin je dois vous avouer que j'ai
hésité à en parler dans ma première
vidéo c'est un concept central en
mécanique quantique mais qui est quand
même un peu abstrait mais bon là je
crois que va falloir y aller
d'habitude quand on fait pas de
mécanique quantique canton pour scène
particules comme un électron c'est assez
pratique de cela représentait comme une
petite boule genre une minuscule balle
de tennis qui aurait une certaine
position une certaine vitesse sauf que
quand on pense à une balle de tennis en
mouvement elle a pas seulement une
position et une vitesse mais elle peut
aussi tourner sur elle-même et c'est
d'ailleurs bien pratique ce mouvement de
rotation sur elle-même parce que c'est
ce qui permet au tennisman de mettre des
effets comme par exemple le lift non
c'est une balle de tennis elle peut
tourner sur elle-même fait ce qu'un
électron il pourrait pas faire pareil
oui le problème c'est que pour autant
qu'on sache un électron c'est pas comme
une petite balle un électron s'est fait
de rien ça a pas de taille alors on voit
pas très bien comment il pourrait
tourner sur lui-même
et puis surtout comment on pourrait s'en
rendre compte oui sauf que l'électron il
a une charge
il est chargé négativement imaginons une
balle de tennis qui serait chargé aussi
et qui aurait par exemple des petites
charges à sa surface
je remercie l tourner sur elle-même elle
se mettrait à se comporter comme un
aimant ça peut vous paraître étrange
comme idée mais pour vous en convaincre
vous pouvez vous rendre compte que
décharge électrique qui tourne en cercle
comme ça c'est exactement le principe de
l'électro aimant qu'on peut faire en
faisant des spirales avec un fil
électrique vient donc une balle de
tennis en rotation si elle était chargée
elle se comporterait comme un aimant
donc non électrons qui sont chargées
négativement basse il était en rotation
sur eux mêmes qui devraient eux aussi
réagir comme des petits aimants et bien
figurez vous que c'est ce qu'on constate
dans certaines expériences notamment
quand on balance certains atomes dans un
champ magnétique du fait que les
électrons se comportent comme des petits
élans les atomes peuvent être déliés par
le chant et on a plein d'autres
expériences qui vont dans le même sens
et qui semble montrer que effectivement
les électrons réagissent comme des
petits aimants et donc tout se passe
comme s'il était en rotation sur eux
mêmes et pour désigner ça on dit que les
électrons possède un spin de l'anglais
spin pour tourner
ce qui est important de comprendre c'est
que les électrons ils sont pas en
rotation sur eux mêmes on a dit ils sont
faits de rien ils n'ont pas de taille
donc on voit pas très bien comment il
pourrait être en rotation physique et
pourtant ils ont quand même cette
propriété de spin qu'on appelle une
propriété intrinsèque
alors c'est un petit peu difficile de se
représenter ce que c'est qu'une
propriété intrinsèque mais par exemple
vous pouvez penser à la masse c'est vrai
quand on trouve que l'électron à une
certaine masse on pourrait être tenté
d'imaginer que l'électron possède un
certain volume physique qui les fait
d'une matière qui a une certaine densité
et que sa masse c'est son volume fois sa
densité
mais non en fait il n'y a pas de volume
et sa masse c'est une propriété
intrinsèque qui ne nécessite pas que
l'électron est une taille physique pour
exister
eh ben le spin c'est pareil tout se
passe comme si l'électron avait une
taille physique et tourner sur lui même
mais en fait il tourne pas sur lui même
mais on appelle ça quand même le sprint
mais il ya encore plus bizarre je vous
ai dit que le spin
il était à l'origine de la déviation de
certains atomes dans un champ magnétique
et intuitivement on s'attendrait à ce
que l'ampleur de la déviation elle soit
liée à l'intensité et à l'orientation du
speed et donc on s'attendrait à voir des
atomes qui serait plus ou moins délier
dans un sens ou dans un autre
voire pas dévié de tous pour certains
sauf que c'est parce qu'on observe pour
un réglage données d'expérience qu'on
observe c'est que les atomes sont
toujours des vielles soit d'une certaine
quantité vers le haut soit de la même
quantité vers le bas mais pas plus et
jamais entre les deux c'est comme si
pour un électron le spin n'avait que
deux valeurs possibles c'est tout et du
coup ces deux valeurs on les note
généralement plus est - ou alors une
petite flèche vers le haut et une petite
flèche vers le bas ça vous rappelle rien
ça le spleen c'est ce qu'on appelle une
propriété quantifier c'est à dire que
comme les niveaux d'énergie de l'atome
d'hydrogène
elle peut prendre que un certain nombre
de valeurs possibles et en l'occurrence
ici seulement deux valeurs
alors c'est assez bizarre mais vous
allez voir que c'est aussi assez
pratique
pourquoi est-ce que le spin est si
important en mécanique quantique et ben
parce que c'est la propriété quantique
la plus simple qu'on connaisse
puisqu'elle peut prendre que deux
valeurs en eau en barque et puis bien
sûr toutes les superpositions de ces 2
et arte
bah oui on fait quand même de la
mécanique quantique là et avoir
seulement deux étages superposés c'est
quand même très pratique pour faire des
calculs
on est loin de ces électrons qui peuvent
être n'importe où dans l'espace qu'il
faut décrire avec une ombre de
probabilités et c'est là non seulement
deux états et pour faire des expériences
c'est aussi beaucoup plus simple et donc
si on réinterprète l'expérience de
déviation dans un champ magnétique avec
le langage de la mécanique quantique
en gros on a qu'il est possible d'avoir
des électrons qui soit dans une
superposition d'états plus et moins au
départ et que si on les balance dans un
champ magnétique 50% des électrons
choisi au hasard voix il dévie vers le
haut et se retrouveront projeté dans
l'état plus et 50% vont aller vers le
bas et seront projetés dans l'état moi
ça c'est l'interprétation usuel de la
mécanique quantique
mais si on vient à notre troupe de
débarquer ce qui nous prouve que c'est
vraiment ça qui se passe et pas plutôt
que dès le départ on avait 50 % des
électrons qui était dans l'état plus et
50% des électrons qui était dans l'état
- et qui est pas du tout de
superposition de projection et c est ça
d'une certaine manière c'était ce que
pensent et einstein
alors je vous ai dit tout à l'heure dans
son débat avec bord il avait fini par
trouver un argument qui tue pour réfuté
l'interprétation traditionnelle de la
mécanique quantique
mais pour comprendre son argument il
faut qu'on passe à deux électrons si on
a deux électrons on a donc deux spin et
si pour commencer on ignore le fait
qu'on puisse faire des superpositions on
a quatre situations possibles les deux
électrons sont dans l'état plus ou alors
le premier et plus et le second est
moins ou bien le premier mois elle se
rouler plus et enfin les deux sont moins
et si maintenant on admet qu'en
mécanique quantique on peut avoir
superposition de plusieurs états eh ben
on peut être dans un mélange de ces
quatre situations est une chose que vous
souvenez peut-être de ma première vidéo
c'est que quand on fait des
superpositions d'état on peut faire
varier les proportions un peu comme dans
un cocktail et parmi toutes les
superpositions possible coriatt de spin
il y en a une qui est particulièrement
intrigante c'est celle où on superpose
uniquement les deux états plus - et -
plus
cette superposition c'est ce qu'on
appelle un état intriqués est la raison
de cette appellation c'est que quand de
particules sont dans cet état elle se
retrouve irrémédiablement liées l'une à
l'autre
on va voir pourquoi imaginer qu'on
mesure le spi du premier électrons on a
une chance sur deux de le trouver dans
l'état plus c'est une chance sur deux de
le trouver dans l'état - sauf que
supposons qu'on le trouve effectivement
mettons dans l'état - vous voyez que ça
signifie que le second électrons lui il
est obligatoirement dans l'état plus et
réciproquement
c'est à dire qu'une fois qu'on a mesuré
le spin d'un des électrons celui de
l'autre ils se trouvent obligatoirement
déterminer les deux mesures elles
doivent forcément correspondre et c'est
pour ça qu'on dit que les deux
particules sont dans un état intriqués
et c'est en utilisant cette situation
qu'einstein à proposer une expérience de
pensée qui pour lui allait démolir
l'interprétation traditionnelle de la
mécanique quantique en 1935 avec deux
autres physiciens podolski et rosanne
einstein a publié un article
scientifique qui présentait un paradoxe
qui depuis portent leurs initiales on
appelle ça le paradoxe le prg idc la
suivante
imaginez qu'on ait deux électrons dans
un état intriqués plus ou moins et moins
plus superposés et qu'on éloigne les
deux électrons l'un de l'autre
imaginons qu'on mesure le spleen du
premier et qu'après on mesure le spin du
second si on en croit l'interprétation
usuel de la mécanique quantique temps
que la première mesure n'a pas été fait
le résultat il est indéterminée on a
toujours un état superposé et c'est la
première mesure qui en quelque sorte
choisi le résultat au hasard entre plus
et moi sauf que pour que le résultat de
la deuxième mesure soit en accord avec
celui de la première on a envie de
penser qu'il faut que quelque chose se
transmettent pour lui communiquer le
résultat pour pourquoi pas sauf que ce
que remarque einstein podolsky rosen
c'est que si on éloigne suffisamment les
électrons qui est qu'on fait les mesures
suffisamment proches presque
simultanément cette transmission il
faudrait qu'elle aille plus vite que la
vitesse de la lumière
horenstein était bien placé pour savoir
que rien ne peut aller plus vite que la
vitesse de la lumière puisque c'est lui
qui avait formalisé cette idée dans sa
théorie de la relativité restreinte et
donc de ce paradoxe
pf einstein conclut qu'il ya forcément
un problème avec la mécanique quantique
tel qu'on l'avait proposé à l'époque et
notamment avec ses idées d'état
superposés et de hasard qui choisiraient
le résultat de la mesure pour lui une
manière plus raisonnable d'envisager les
choses c'est d'imaginer que la
description avec superposition d'états
elle est incomplète et qui a forcément
de l'information supplémentaire quelque
part par exemple on pourrait imaginer
que quand les électrons se séparent ils
se mettent d'accord secrètement sur quel
état ils vont tomber si jamais il ya
deux mesures
et ça ça permettrait d'éliminer à la
fois l'idée de hasard et en plus le
besoin d'avoir une transmission plus
rapide que la vitesse de la lumière
cette vision c'est celle qu'on appelle
parfois celle des variables cachées
parce qu'elle considère qu'il ya des
variables supplémentaires qui sont
cachés mais qui conditionne le résultat
des mesures
c'est un petit peu comme quand on lance
une pièce à pile ou face vous savez on a
l'impression que c'est le hasard qui
choisit mais en fait il ya des variables
qui sont cachés comme la position de la
pièce sa vitesse de rotation etc et qui
détermine à l'avance le résultat de la
mesure si on connaissait ces variables
on serait capable de prédire sur quel
côté la pièce va tomber et donc grâce à
ce paradoxe le prg stagne pensait qu'il
avait gagné le débat avec bord jusque
rien ne peut aller plus vite que la
lumière cette expérience de pensée
elle montre qui a forcément des
variables cachées en mécanique quantique
et donc que la mécanique quantique est
incomplète
alors à l'époque en 1935 einstein avait
proposé ça comme une expérience de
pensée
elstat il faisait toujours des
expériences de pensée il faisait jamais
l'aiderait expérience ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que depuis cette expérience on a
réussi à la faire alors en pratique on
utilise généralement pas des électrons
mais on utilise plutôt des photons et
c'est pas leur spleen qu'on mesure
seller polarisation mais bon pour nous
ça revient à peu près au même
la figurez-vous que l'expérience se
passe exactement comme prévu par le
paradoxe hop et r si on fabrique deux
photons dans un état un truc et on les
sépare et compte sur la polarisation de
l'ain et ben ça détermine
automatiquement et immédiatement la
polarisation de l'autre et à distance et
quelle que soit la distance qui les
sépare le record actuel c'est quand même
13 km
ça veut dire que dans l'expérience tout
se passe comme si un photon était
capable d'influencer un autre faute ont
quasiment instantanément à 13 km de
distance et donc si on suit einstein
c'est forcément que il ya des variables
cachées quelque part
à moins qu einstein et or est que cette
influence se instantané à distance elle
existe vraiment alors les choses
auraient pu en rester là sauf que dans
les années 60 un mathématicien du nom de
bell a proposé un moyen de trancher le
débat par l'expérience est de savoir
s'il y avait vraiment des variables
cachées ou pas parce qu'elle démontre
est belle c'est un petit peu technique
alors je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais ça concerne en gros ce qui
se passe quand on mesure le lien entre
les polarisations des de particules en
mettant un angle légèrement différent
entre les deux détecteurs et ce qu'a
démontré belle sait que dans une théorie
à variables cachées
la corrélation entre les deux mesures
elle obéit forcément à certaines
inégalités
on appelle ça les inégalités de bell
alors qu'en mécanique quantique en tout
cas selon son interprétation
traditionnels d'après les calculs on
doit avoir des corrélations plus élevé
que ces inégalités
on dit que la mécanique quantique
violent les inégalités de bell ce
résultat théorique très important de
bell il a ouvert la voie à un moyen de
trancher le débat entre einstein et
l'étonnant de l'interprétation de
copenhague voir einstein était déjà mort
mais pas grave et cette expérience elle
a été réalisée pour la première fois par
une équipe française celle d'allah
aspects à orsay en 1990 alain aspect qui
est un spécialiste de l'optique et des
lasers a montré que dans son montage
particulier qui
lise la polarisation des photons les
inégalités de bell était violée ce
résultat il peut vous paraître un petit
peu abstrait mais ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que cette expérience elle montre
que la mécanique quantique ne peut pas
être une théorie à variables cachées et
que donc
einstein avait tort et que
l'interprétation de copenhague sel de
bore et compagnie elle tient la route
il n'y a pas de varier de cachet et
c'est a priori bien le hasard qui
détermine le résultat des mesures
l'expérience d'alain espèce est vraiment
une expérience fondatrice c'est une des
plus importantes de la mécanique
quantique et peut-être même de toute la
physique
d'ailleurs je sais pas pourquoi il a
toujours pas eu prix nobel un le bon et
pourtant l'expérience d'aspect elle
avait quelques failles
alors qu'en temps normal on n'aura
peut-être pas été très regardant mais là
la question elle est tellement
fondamentale que si on se fait un peu
l'avocat du diable on peut se dire que
il subsiste un petit doute et que donc
peut-être que quand même il ya des
variables cachées en mécanique quantique
et donc depuis les années 80 il ya eu
plein de groupes de recherche dans le
monde qui ont essayé de faire des
expériences similaires à celles dernier
aspect en essayant de corriger les
failles et elles ont montré que toutes
les failles pouvait être corrigé 1 et
les expériences confirme à chaque fois
le résultat d'aspect et son équipe
les inégalités de bell sont violées et
qui peut pas y avoir deux variables
cachées
sauf que jusqu'ici on avait montré qu'il
était possible de corriger toutes les
failles une par une
mais jamais tout en même temps et donc
on n'avait pas d'expérience analogue à
celle d'alain aspect qui corrige toutes
les failles à la fois et en octobre 2015
il ya une équipe de recherche à
l'université de delft aux pays-bas qui a
pour la première fois publié les
résultats d'une expérience dans lesquels
toutes les failles ont été corrigés eh
bien figurez vous que ça marche toujours
les inégalités de bell sont violés
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de tout ça
et bien tout d'abord que
l'interprétation qu'on donne usuellement
de la mécanique quantique avec ces états
superposés
le hasard qui intervient dans les
mesures la projection etc ça s'en tenir
la route
au début de la vidéo on s'était demandé
si les états superposés et le hasard
quantique dans les mesures existent
vraiment ou si c'était juste le résultat
de notre ignorance de l'état exact des
particules dès le départ
sauf qu'il ya quand même un prix à payer
pour tout ça souvenez-vous du paradoxe
de p r le fait qu'ils aient des états
intrigués nous oblige à admettre la
possibilité que des mesures peuvent
s'influencer plus vite que la vitesse de
la lumière
alors est-ce que ça viole pas la
relativité restreinte ça qu'est-ce qui
se passe et ben non en fait la violation
des inégalités de bell est le paradoxe
au père ne sont pas en contradiction
avec la relativité restreinte alors
l'argument détails et il est assez
technique mais il faut vous imaginer que
en gros on peut pas utiliser ça pour
faire de la communication à distance
parce que quand il ya une mesure le
résultat il est déterminé au hasard vous
n'êtes pas moyen de choisir le résultat
vous le subissent et est donc vous
pouvez pas utiliser le paradoxe se perd
et les était intrigué pour vraiment
communiquer à distance
l'autre mot il faut préciser c'est que
les expériences d'aspect et la violation
des inégalités de bell
elles permettent d'exclure que les
théories à variables cachées dit locale
en fait on peut sauver le déterminisme
et l'idée des variables cachées
si on les autorise à être non local
c'est-à-dire ne pas être attachés à un
point de l'espace mais en quelque sorte
exister à plusieurs endroits à la fois
au final ce qu'il faut retenir de ces
idées d'intrication c'est que la
mécanique quantique aussi loin qu on la
teste
elle continue de se comporter de manière
toujours plus surprenante est contraire
à notre intuition et pourtant ainsi que
la façon d'invention elle marche
diaboliquement bien merci d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à la partager notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux puisque c'est la
meilleure chose que vous puissiez faire
pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne
merci à tous ceux qui me soutiennent
tipi merci beaucoup moins mauvais
peut-être remarqué que la qualité des
vidéos s'améliore de jour en jour c'est
grâce à vos lecteurs merci beaucoup
et enfin comme souvent pour ceux qui
voudraient aller un petit peu plus loin
savoir un petit peu plus sur le paradoxe
e p r les inégalités de bell etc
j'ai un petit billet que je mettrai en
lien quelque part par ici voilà et puis
se termine par une petite annonce le 7
février je serai à lyon pour le festival
lyon sciences donc n'hésitez pas à aller
voir le lien que je mettrais quelque
part vous pouvez notamment soutenir
l'organisation du festival n'hésitez pas
à le faire
et puis vous pouvez donc venir le 7
février
a lyon science sa sera l'occasion de se
rencontrer et puis y aura pas que moi il
y aura plein d'autres gens bien il y
aura sébastien carassou du cnsof fender
il y aura florence porcel il y aura
liaison berne et enfin voilà il y aura
plein de gens autour de la vulgarisation
scientifique donc le 7 février à lyon
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup de m'avoir suivi et puis à
bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos